what type of gifts are okay to re-gift
and which are not wah-bah be pillows we
get that [ __ ] all day we gift socks cuz
Sox are like what's their cool yeah I
mean as long as they're not worn yeah I
mean they're just [ __ ] gifts that
people give people like I do a tooth
like like I'll just go to Starbucks and
get a gift card gift card yeah you mean
or socks you know like if you're gonna
cut if you're not gonna [ __ ] spend
some money or beasts legitimate about it
then it's like don't bother bro you
don't mean dog I you know like my
brother [ __ ] got me a pocket [ __ ] I
told you that he had you already used it
no we give teen sex toys do not reduce
sex toy I think he didn't wash it yeah
you know like go and buy an iPod suite
that's like the his most prized
possession possibly no because it
doesn't work anymore the reason why he
gave it to me because it was ripped it
was ripped and then he's yeah and it's
already it's done yeah you're my brother
mi sceptile he gave me a pack of
cigarettes he smoked half the pack you
know he's done that he's done stuff like
that and he's given me socks before so
now my brother and I just understand we
don't just don't we don't nothing well
your brother though is very considerate
with me
there isn't a birthday or a Christmas
that he doesn't wrap something for me
and write a card for me Oh Steve is very
cute like that he's not like you he does
care and even if it's not they're not
expensive don't even get me started
woman don't even get me started
I like gestures like that I love your
brother you you're good too you're the
best best I'm the best you're the
Emperor error you made another [ __ ]
question man this is from a TFS tes
feels on Tiger belly Instagram any plans
for Bobby to do a comedy tour in
Australia don't before is it listen
listen anyway
listening in Australia I want to [ __ ]
go there mm-hmm
I want to do it shows Joe Neil now but
but but the [ __ ] festivals is tough
have to bring me over there
somebody has to contact me and go let's
do this but I'm not gonna just show up
with my backpack and go to a comedy club
and go hey can I go up it's got it's a
different country it's gonna be out it
I've done it in South Africa but it was
a festival I was there for two months
and I did it with a bunch of guys I know
that they have festivals in Australia
[ __ ] just invite me so if you're
listening to Australia you know a dude
that knows a dude Ryan get that dude to
call my and then make it happen mm-hmm
you know I want to go yep
[Music]